brought that uh an athlete aspect into
it and apparently it is messy that
lemonaronian is wearing as the game in
the semi-final has started yep it's a
queen's pawn opening will we see a
transposition to the queen's gambit now
if white brings the knight out if black
challenges for the center with his pawn
it is the queen's gambit and this
position um very common they've had this
against each other several times before
throughout the tour which actually
included players like anish giri they
just weren't watching his games
that's why these players like magnus
they go back every day and watch or kind
of play through all of the games that
happened that day initiate these sets of
trades
okay white capturing a pawn but ironian
not recapturing yet and pawns are
starting to disappear black now is going
to take that white pawn in the center
the one that has just moved you can take
with the knight as well
okay he takes with the pawn you could
take with a knight just putting pressure
on white tonight but i was gonna say if
he took with the queen this would be
maybe the most passive approach offering
a queen trade and due to this pin the
white knight cannot take the black queen
instead let's go back to the game he
took with the pawn but the downside here
is that black has an isolated pawn it's
either a strength or weakness might
brought his bishop out to create a pin
and black just defended his isolated
pawn and wow okay things are heating up
because magnus he's not even flinching
he's castled to the left side he's
passing long but look how open this king
is right now and levon says okay i'm
going to castle my king too but compare
the kings black's king safest houses
behind a wall of pawns magnus is king
super open why would magnus go that way
it's super safe the other way because
it's all been played before kaya ah and
the queens are coming off okay this is
crazy um white's rook now gets to take
the black queen but black's bishop takes
the white queen and in a fancy way we
have seen a temporary peace sacrifice by
levon aronian he's saying you can take
my bishop but in return i'm going to get
your knight and everything is going to
get simplified here
i'm expecting white's knight actually to
move it has moved and now this bishop is
simply going to retreat it has to find a
safe square most likely it goes back and
despite the fact the queens are off
white's key is still a bit open and
everything else is balanced right now so
let's go back to the board all the
trades are happening things are getting
hovered off the players have studied
this before this morning this is clear
yes wait so you're saying it's going to
be a draw
not necessarily but it's leading to a
draw-ish position so like a level uh
position so if we fast-forward after a
few more trades we see okay both sides
have strong nights white still has to
catch up in development peace
development because the bishop and rook
is still at home and that means that
black is happy despite the fact he's
temporarily a pawn down white has a
three versus two advantage on this side
but that's not relevant at the moment
this looks like the type of thing where
magnus is saying okay i'm gonna test you
if you know your stuff then it's just
going to be level if you don't know your
stuff then white has a big advantage but
aronia you can see on this clock time
he's actually gained time since the game
started and traditionally he quite likes
these positions but it's going to be
hard to outmaneuver levon with so few
pieces remaining create some threats
because the main thing okay white's
knight kicked away there and retreating
black restoring the material balance um
but if we look at the pawn structure
white has these three versus two on the
right side black has two verses one on
the other flank
that does mean that if all the pieces
come off it will be a pawn race and it's
not clear whose side is uh which side is
going to be quicker to create past pawns
then they will stand some chances
meanwhile iranian just
he's got that hoover out he's saying
okay we've taken everything off let's
get the knights off the board as well
the one thing speaking in white's favor
and is that all because he did castle
queen side alongside yeah closer to the
center yeah four square suddenly it's an
aggressive king starting to look at some
pawns and
okay well we see some trades and
normally when we have such a simplified
end game such as this this is quite a
significant turn of events because every
trade has an impact on the position and
uh okay pretty promising in this
scenario because at this point is so
weak so so vulnerable that's why levon
he couldn't trade off the bishops it was
simply a big mistake so he brings his
king into the action he's going to try
and centralize his king if possible also
trying to defend this uh this weakness
but the white king now will stop
marching yeah white's king is marching
and it's going to try and destabilize
this black rook
and okay a few moves the black pawn
pushing forward but suddenly it's a bit
shaky for black blacks were forced to
step back to defend the pawn next to it
and
i still don't see a breakthrough for
white but white is definitely the one in
charge for example okay he fixes the
structure fixing this pawn on a light
square so that later on it can be a
target for white's bishop a very
sophisticated move there i i like it
fixing those long-term weaknesses good
in-game strategy i think uh okay black's
reduced to a just kind of wait-and-see
strategy black is just going to maybe
move the rook back and forth back and
forth but meanwhile white still lacks
pawn breaks white can't break through on
the left side of the board because this
is where black has the strengths and
meanwhile it does feel like uh
you have to at some point start pushing
forward on the side white is stronger
that's the only way to make progress
long-term that i see meanwhile magnus
just waiting with his bishop there
and okay i expect to see levon aronian
do the same
no okay
lavon i think is going to be inviting
magnus to repeat the position three
times a draw here is great for levon
right right
okay magnus says no let's play and that
improves his the placing of his rook
moving it to the fifth row eyeing up
that weak pawn on f5 white doesn't
attack it yet just
yo-yoing back and forth with the bishop
it just passes levon's passing with his
bishop he's like okay
let's wait just said ah is that an irish
yeah i was gonna ask is it irish i think
so yeah yeah it is
playing some chopin pieces while waiting
for david ivanka and kaya on the chest
show makes me happy
and
still the bishops are dancing merrily
away white only okay he brings this rook
across no threat still just nice and
pretty and erroneous says okay i'm going
to challenge your rook you don't
necessarily want that okay he does trade
it's still fine but i think this is a
bit risky i was surprised actually i
thought maybe the trade might happen but
uh in a different way okay so the king
now moves over sharply to the left and
it's guarding those critical squares
remember just looking at it objectively
there's no entry points for the black
king yeah i guess the black king is tied
down to the pawn the that f5 pawn and
maybe magnus has some ambitious
intentions maybe he's going to try and
bring his bishop to the side challenge
black's bishop no he doesn't do that the
white king the promise it can't step
forward is controlled by the black
bishop and black pawns and if you can't
step forward
no way through for the white king no way
through for the black king either that
magnus carlsen can just squeeze magic
out of nothing yeah yes is it the thing
for that here or is it yeah but this
this is uh
a different type of nothing position
because i mean just take a look at it i
mean
none of the work the kings can actually
penetrate into the position especially
after levon's last move
and uh this makes the position
relatively simple and the players are
repeating moves
i think we are good
bishops i know yeah there we go it is a
draw at the position repeating itself
three times no way through and uh good
start for level neronian yeah
levon messi
a good start with the black pieces i
draw in the first game